pierre semaine la prise de contrôle des
gonaïves par les rebelles est hautement
symbolique cette ville est en effet le
berceau de toutes les contestations
c'est là que fut proclamé l'indépendance
d'haïti il ya 200 ans
c'est là aussi que commença il ya vingt
ans la lutte contre l'ancien dictateur
jean claude duvalier
sur place le reportage de jean marc
pitte et denis bassompierre qui vous a
été confié et poussait au fond de la
sphère les esprits du vaudou et les
saints catholiques sont régulièrement
invoqué sur ce carrefour de quatre
chemins où reposent amiotte métayer
c'est le 21 septembre dernier que l'on a
retrouvé le corps de ce partisans
d'aristide assassiné son cadavre portait
les traces de torture virtuel
pour ces soldats de l'armée cannibale
des gonaïves
tout est clair c'est le président
aristide qui est responsable du martyre
de leur général dans un premier temps il
s'est servi des chefs de gangs pour
tenir les quartiers populaires imposer
sa loi et combattre toute forme
d'opposition
mais il a cédé aux pressions américaines
qui le sommait de les arrêter mais
amiotte métayer en savait trop sur les
crimes du pouvoir le palais a donc
préféré l'éliminer depuis lors ces
hommes manifestent presque chaque soir
leur haine d'aristide la ville des
gonaïves n'est pas seul c'est le pays
tout entier qui va se soulever contre
lui les gonaïves
c'est la poudrière d'haïti il y a deux
siècles exactement c'est ici qu'a été
arraché l'indépendance de la première
république noire en 1986 de là encore
que son parti les premières
manifestations qui devaient conduire à
la chute de jean claude duvalier
aujourd'hui cette ville est la première
à tomber aux mains des rebelles depuis
la mort d'amiante métayer le quartier de
raboteau fief de l'armée cannibale avait
déjà proclamé sa sécession
les raids de la police il y avait fait
en quatre mois une soixantaine de morts
mais ils n'ont réussi qu'à radicaliser
un peu plus les anciens soutiens du
président
nous avons combattu vous mettre à
l'essai de pouvoir nous avons résisté
pendant trois ans pour son retour
maintenant s'il fait c'est comme celle
entre des pommettes et gabegie
administrative des traîtres des crimes
contre la population
c'est à nos hôtes ont également de dire
en premier
tu as reçu doit pâture en échange de sa
fidélité
aristide avait concédé à 7 min ce le
droit de percevoir les taxes portuaires
et les frais de dédouanement
en clair ils achetaient muscles et
complicité il nous a donné de l'argent
et des armes pour le soutenir et le
bakoye pour combattre l'opposition mais
nous ne savions pas qu'il tuerait les
premiers dons
les quelques dizaines de combattants de
l'armée cannibale assure vouloir en
finir avec ce système quasi féodale ils
promettent que leur combat contre
aristide sera le dernier
décarie stick sera mettront toutes ces
armes que vous voyez entre les mains des
nouvelles autorités
parce que nous sommes pas des
terroristes nous ne voulons pas porter
les armes mais pour toute votre vie
mais pour l'heure et depuis quatre mois
déjà la vie s'est arrêtée à raboteau et
seule la violence et la résistance ont
encore un sens